hello I'm Xena Badawi welcome to the
concert hall in Stockholm where the
Nobel Prize winners received their
awards from the king of Sweden for their
outstanding contributions to science
literature and economics this is the
first time that this year's laureates
are appearing together on television and
they've been joined by their family and
friends who've travelled to Stockholm to
share in the celebrations and we are
also joined by students from here in
Sweden who are going to be putting their
questions to our laureates
on this year's noble minds we have
discoveries on repairing damaged DNA
which increase our knowledge of the
universe cure tropical diseases and in
economics we throw light on the links
between poverty consumption and welfare
and the literature prize gives voice to
the voiceless in authoritarian societies
laureates congratulations to you all
wonderful let's go straightaway to our
first question from our audience here
and it is Martin Martin please your
first question to our laureates so there
are a lot of the prizes and competitions
in all of your fields and I just wanted
to have your opinion do you think it is
a good addition to motivate people to
get engaged or do you think it inspires
unnecessary competition uh-huh
so Angus Deaton well economists are
never competitive we have something
called perfect competition which
economists believe in I'm not sure the
Nobel does much of that I've been very
impressed by how much positive just
general happiness and well-being it
seems to generate it's clear though over
the years in the past there certainly is
some resentment on behalf of people who
don't win I really hope you had to use
that I've never felt it personally but
you hear discussions blank stares when
you pass by oh I have not experienced
any of that I've been very fortunate
that way but I do think in the past
people have felt that a whole area you
know that should have been recognized
never was recognized for instance and
I'm sure and that's a more legitimate
feeling then I'm sure there are some
people who feel that they should have
been recognized them or not what a
generous man you are professor Deaton in
saying that but I'm sure you deserved
your prize but let me just see what
anybody else Paul moderator professor
moderate well I think it's useful in
bringing visibility to science and feel
I agree with Angus I think that there
have been instances where certain people
have felt certainly in in my field that
the certain areas that were worthy of a
prize were neglected and and so there is
a value judgement I think in selection
of the fields professor Campbell
I think it does not create competition
among scientists don't compete for that
and secondly I think it
it's inevitable and it also adds a nice
little bit of something special that
scientists can enjoy so I think it's
sort of inspirational and not
confrontational and certainly not
inducing not induced of competition and
the chemistry field we've been very
fortunate and that the three winners
worked on different mechanisms of DNA
repair and we had no competition so
we've been fortunate to have it that way
and so in this particular case there was
no competition round off the chemist
professor thomas Lindell yes I think
healthy competition is a good thing
it's excellent if and scientist goes a
little bit of astray with his ideas that
somebody else corrects them and I think
it would be too comfortable if there was
no competition at all huh okay it's
Liana Alexeevich obviously you are the
literature laureate I should say
actually of course everybody that line
Alexeyevich is speaking in Russian and I
know the question was specifically about
science but in terms of receiving the
Nobel Prize as professor Deaton said
it's a very it's a real accolade I mean
do you feel that it's going to help you
in some way do what you do better
yokas to uni lucia badoo badoo flushable
do two chefs Ignacio a mod with
parasites kikuchiyo strategy honesty no
s Cozzetto Prima status Nami a Sabine I
deal with Navi Utley Etta raddest no TJ
worse we deal with us Matrixyl does it
mean a great deal in obelisk a premier
Serrano patio mm-hmm
the physicists professor of McDonald's
and then oh you want to go first
professor gadget ah yes okay well we
both wanted to understand what is the
properties of neutrinos and we have the
same gold and
coming from different experiments and we
very much complementary rather than
compare complementary rather than
competition so I'm getting the sense
Evert Martin your question about it
perhaps encouraging competition is a not
getting much traction here art McDonald
I think the scientists are primarily
motivated by the science they're
attempting to understand our universe
more completely I think they're quite
satisfied when they recognize themselves
that they have made a breakthrough and
have understood things more completely I
think when there is the recognition like
this by such a respected body as the
people who define the Nobel Prize it's
something that is highly respected in
the community it adds to the joy of
having made a significant discovery so
nobody really does anybody resonate
briefly on what professor Deaton said
about some sad damage tormented Souls
going around saying I should have won
the Nobel I could have won the Nobel
it's not fair has anybody come across
any of such individuals I have come more
than why I should have none
Wanda Nobel when you see a major
breakthrough in your field I personally
feel very bad I should have made that
discovery not that I'm right now there
is something called CRISPR
is very hot in our field and I wish I
made that discovery myself I would give
anything for so it's not competition per
se but it is a scientist and individuals
drive to to discover an important thing
thank you for your honesty professor
Sancho all right so now we're moving to
a specific question which is for you
professor Angus Deaton you're of course
the economics laureate and you won your
prize for really shedding a great deal
of light on the links between poverty
consumption and
fare and what implications there are for
policymakers particularly in setting
levels of taxation for instance but
let's see what comes up from our
students andreas I I have a short
question is fighting inequality a
realistic aim it's maybe a short
question though I'm not sure short
answer I mean here I think is the
essence of the matter which is we have
tools to fight inequality you know you
could have in the United States a much
more progressive tax system for instance
you know we could spend more money on
education and less on defense I've heard
as these talk about that and there's
lots of things you could do so the
question is not having the tools so it's
realistic in the sense that we have the
tools all right it's unrealistic in the
sense that the politics is
extraordinarily difficult so you know
the people who have all the money also
have a lot of political power and
they're not very interested in fighting
inequality and so what do you do if you
think there's too much inequality or
inequality is reach dangerous levels
which I do then I think the best thing
to do is is you have to participate in
the democratic process and persuade
other people that it's a problem for
instance by being on a TV show like this
so it is can be done you say but it's a
lack of political will the tools are
there
you mentioned taxation sort of in
passing but just briefly outline for us
then what are the tools that can be used
to reduce inequality well there's a lot
of tax tools I mean one of them for
instance is like an inheritance tax for
example but many of us have always
thought that you know fairly stiff
inheritance taxes were a good thing
because it helps it stops you having
this hereditary inequality what Thomas
Piketty famously is called patrimonial
capitalism is the French economist is
written a lot about inequality that's
right and I think many of us think it's
good for each generation each group of
kids who born each generation
have an equal chance not just depending
on what their parents have and two ways
of doing that one is you know
inheritance taxes another is trying to
equalize the opportunities of schools
and there's a big concern in the United
States and IO that you know the best
schools are going to the kids of the
well-off people and it's very hard much
harder than it was in our generation for
kids for poor families to get into to
get a really first-class education and
that's absolutely vital professor as you
Sandra would you mind my bringing you in
just on this particular point because I
hope you don't mind me saying that you
were born in Turkey or one of eight
children right and your parents could
not read or write
right and here you are a Nobel laureate
completely exemplifying what professor T
so the United States has 25% of total
prisoner population and that has to do
with inequality it has to do with lack
of opportunity and that is a problem I I
think under there there was a recent
article in New England Journal Medicine
comparing the health care system into in
Turkey and in the United States it's
much better than turkey turkey does not
have the those resources the United
States and here we passed the Obama care
which is a universal health care system
and we're still fighting it a group in
the United States still fighting it so
even though I come from a country where
at the resources and and and so on are
not as advanced as as the United States
I think in a certain aspect in terms of
equal opportunity for education
education in Turkey is free you don't
have that in the United States but it
was just your your own individual
personal story illustrates that if
you're given that equality of
opportunity somebody of your background
can
rise tonight and it and and I I wish my
adopted country would take the necessary
steps to do that all right okay thank
you there is another question for you
professor Deaton and that's from David
Gandolfi David thank you professor
Deaton for I'm here and thank 12 the
Nobel laureates my question is
specifically you have expressed some
criticism about foreign aid to poor
countries now why is that okay so let me
start by saying that I'm not critical at
all of the wish to help people in poor
countries but I think a lot of what
we're doing in terms of foreign aid
right now is actually not helping at all
there's lots of things we can do from
the outside which will make the new
innovations the new discoveries and so
on which will help poor countries
I think countries that have very large
aid inflows into the domestic economy
that tends to undermine the sort of
responsible government that you need in
order for development of any chance of
taking place I think the sort of aid I
think of Bill here is my example of
exactly the sort of aid that really
works which is we can spend money in the
United States and Sweden and so on to
get the sort of discoveries that save
millions of lives or save people from
being brown blind that's a sort of eight
so I'm not a blanket against aid but if
we can help spend money I mean Merck
made that drug available through the
World Bank that many people are in the
world do not and you know that that's a
huge gift from rich countries to poor
countries so for you going to give it to
dodgy rulers in Africa because you can't
trust them for what they'll do with it
or we're creating dodgy rulers by you
know basically saying you don't have to
raise anything from your own population
we'll keep you in business by giving you
in norms of sums of money so you know
we're making the dodgy rulers even dodgy
air and that's the the one of the
central prong he's opened up a whole can
of worms the example I know you like
worms we're going to come to that
now a Soviet liner alexeyevitch we come
you you are from Belarus you're
Belarusian and you won the Literature
Prize for your whole body of work that
you've written over many many decades
giving voice to the voiceless you've
written things like voices of Chernobyl
about the ghastly nuclear accident in in
you've written a dinky boys about the
soviet-afghan war when there were young
russian soldiers coming back in zinc
coffins hint
hence Zinke boys talked about women
suffering in the Second World War and
and that has led to a genre that you
described as a documentary novel and the
citation said that you have the soul of
a historian and it in many ways you
write your your works are based on the
testimony of real people so that just by
way of background of your your work but
let's see what the question is for you
and I think that Diana you have a
question Diana yeah for yet Donna so do
you believe your message gets out there
in a better way by using journalistic
methods rather than fictional ones do
tototo styles enemas a animagus cos I'd
set a journalistic attend a journalistic
edit arataura presume or even taco every
Mia kogda tempest reinsertion Draghi
Skouras Drogo Cebu Tina's let's add na
na Drogo my vote version passed I'd need
vivo desk or Kosovo presses law e at
newest Madonna Mia trimming stubble
signal at of so is Ruchika ktem tossed
ome opposite Loretta washable opposite a
Venezuelan a truth when a mere a trove
of reminisce even upcycle a Nieto Nahas
enemas me story
yeah Anna my sister industry llamo is
Anna my proposition a story two story
story a business
Caetano vesica Myrna Thomas todo
Mitchell area
yo tang interior sweetie Oh interior
suet kandar so its Mattel visible Oh
sneaky sobriety cake Akita Figaro Lumina
prosto jetty material ah oh na haute
cavity really an illusion Eliska yeah
yeaaah issued a arrows Guevara is nummy
eros Guevara Teta toes nada heinous
Guevara slid me
Mitaka journalist journalist be rutila
Rica very nice boy
yeah bodacious Kassala banana
information slowly Yarborough
rocket of Chile hsk destroy observe iets
cut kokosh totem press hold it but you
have also like a journalists been very
political and very outspoken in your
criticisms both of president Lukashenko
of better Belarus and your half
Ukrainians so you've also been very
critical of President Putin and his
actions in Ukraine particularly over
Crimea and so on so I think a lot of
people are very interested in what you
have to say about the current political
situation that is going on in the former
Soviet Union and I wonder if he would
just briefly give us an idea of how you
see things evolving in that part of the
world
acha lacrosse de Cultura Tesla's
personal rasca quarter II a rosca
culture a pop art Cinda empire
at a classic a forma Bremen push Pina
llena de sibour
Estella's but a most muster in a
revamped oi Illinois stepping after eat
our Nexus team iPod atomo - it's a
ghetto Vogel oak ideality vetoed
invasive civil atewa metastatic easy neo
Skakel Torre impose Valley Tenaglia ros
cava Pistoleros copasetic Matthias
Sammer possibly sir shanab Ricard little
area E
Rabbitohs really blue denote a true T
Postigo twat
capri Rhonda at the scientist at the
Schnee interiors what no selenium
research and a drug a stockist is a
tvasta priests who depress avoid neva
tunas prosciutto chippy channel
myopically Nia talked ad LEP destroy PO
Missouri on Canada chosen progeny me
pack a pili progeny Yabo's Cazalas toe
Mui miss Paul Vallas way sons Dylan
hasta God Oh vato trans con dar CM way
at Crete verily stow star a mere paas ad
e is this V Amita Musa beresch Tommy
Williams risk account visa pass number
circumcision Miri what attack as an
assertion in attack but a most swaboda
newzeas Avista Cox it's ours Ishika
wotty little hints go boom abu allah
bentley el Cucuy tisha novo modle
machinee swaboda a chance la jeunesse
tiny yet 'no capellini at nas no no
Gabrielle
pretty data washable a tomato casita
Sapna Rosalie da casita Spinelli namja
Cazalas caboose Rizzo
thank you we have another question for
Svetlana from Jamie right now the world
is faced with a huge challenges such a
climate change ongoing conflicts and
waves of refugees who flee in the
countries with this in mind what makes
you optimistic about the future of
mankind
humanity so sweet lana Alexeevich that's
a question for you briefly if you would
be so kind as to answer that question
because I have to say you have been
described as a writer of catastrophes
have an idea yenicall a nice a glossary
a positive catastrophe
but the most oh no siree make our
society sure globally da tosya issue
Nakata Nick Alexander oozes yeah
collection Archie Letts kiddo
star itsy-bitsy LaRocca
Sahara Nitze Beach Aliyeva
Tata me until I saw it yeah do my oh
yeah Vasek on so Chiana deist oh-hoh
tenedor jQuery ANCA
so tacky sir take mu D mu da da da da da
rocha tonighti wicked hasta Tichina is
true de novo brimming of keturah macaws
Alice Nestle Vinny Martina potato boost
Alex cook Nick Otomo's nos Gazette
sadistic Dajjal a business rival Amina
thank you very much indeed
Svetlana thank you so I think now we
move to a specific question for the
professor William Campbell one of the
three medicine and physiology laureates
but your two colleagues are not with us
you you two from China who was awarded
the prize for discovering a very
effective malaria treatment artemisinin
derived from natural plants interesting
enough she actually went and referred to
chinese book on a on medicine Chinese
medicine which is 1700 years old but you
were also awarded the prize professor
Campbell with Professor Amira
from Japan and he sent you some soil
when he sent the Institute that you're
working at some soil samples and from
that you managed to derive treatment for
terrible tropical diseases
elephantiasis where the limbs really
swell and river blindness which is a
terrible affliction that has ruined
lives millions of lives so that's what
you won the prize for but let's hear
what the question is from Jeremy Jeremy
Falls
forsberg Jeremy thank you professor
Campo where do you think that the next
generation of antibiotics will come from
are they coming primarily from the
nature itself yes I think they are most
likely to come from nature and I think
we
have approached this naively in the past
we sometimes get caught up with very
sophisticated modern technology and its
possibilities of finding new drugs it's
odd and reassuring to me that all three
of us involved in this particular prize
worked with plants or products of nature
and I recently made a proposal arcing
back to what I've been making for over
40 years but my proposal now is to have
a much greater scouring of the world for
novel microorganisms or animals or
plants that may provide the next leads
and there are talents out there that I
think could it be brought to bear
you know if countries can put men
outside of the earth and bring them back
to earth one would think they could
solve some of these problems but when
you were working on trial on what led to
ivermectin and you talked about how you
went to Togo in Africa and it was really
uplifting for you to see the children
being treated from this terrible illness
which their parents and grandparents you
know literally rendered blind was that a
motivating factor for you this sort of
compassion was that part of the was not
a motivation for think it'd be it was
inspirational to me it was uplifting for
me it was a fabulous thing for me but
most researchers even in medical fields
setting aside certain idealistic
positions but most researchers in
medical field are interested in the
research and they are interested in
doing research that might turn out to be
good but their motivation is basically
their curiosity the scientific challenge
certainly with that thought that the
great of this is useful but no
discussion it's not done for reasons of
compassion I think that's a equanimous
understand
but also by way of perspective let me
say this that when I was employed by the
merck pharmaceutical company many years
ago I was employed specifically and
solely to try and find a new drug for
schistosomiasis a tropical disease
sometimes called snail fever and that's
the hot seat to build hearts our bill
heart Isis and I worked in that solely
focused on that for seven years I had an
unblemished record of failure and I had
a wonderful time doing it I was not a
slightest bit discouraged I intended to
spend with the rest of my life doing it
but I got into a lot of other things and
that project was carried on by other
people in my department for many many
years I was never asked to stop doing it
I never ceased to be funded for doing it
I think there are lots of discussion we
should have about that anybody pick up
although despite this breakthrough of
treating these terrible diseases
compassion was not a necessarily the
motivating factor yeah professor Lindell
we work on cancer research so people
also all the time
are you finding any new drugs for cancer
assort when can we cure cancer and I
hope that will be an important
consequence of what we are doing but as
I see it it's still a side effect of
what we are doing what we are really
trying to do is understand the world we
are living in how cells function once we
know that we can develop no drugs and
all kinds of other nice things I have
follow-up yeah I have not been this
jealous of Nobel Prize in medicine and
in my entire life I really mark
when I heard it I said this is the way
to give know about stuff is somebody
yeah I had the lab meeting that morning
I ran in we usually discuss our
experiments and I just didn't discuss
the experiment I discussed noble in
medicine and I discussed heroes and
these guys are my here yeah absolutely
what they did can I say their professor
Sandra is somebody who's an expert in
DNA and maybe genes and that Canadian
you might try and isolate the MV gene
and use yourself and then average twice
about everything else so well that is
sincere the the chemist Nobel laureates
have come in here chemistry Nobel
laureates let's go to our specific
question on your your work on repairing
damaged DNA Emma M Eriksen you have a
question do you think that the future
strategy of curing cancer will be to
repair the reparation systems of DNA or
will the changes in behavior be more
important
so should people change their behavior
pulmonic all right yeah certain
behaviors are directly caused cancer
smoking is one out of it well I'm not
going to that my person you're my person
you're clearly a man who enjoys a tip
like I drink alcohol but my personal
belief is that had alcohol itself is not
known to be a carcinogen but one of its
metabolic products is and and I think
it's quite clear that certain it's
probable in my view that certain food
products may have cancer-causing could
you say some food products is that
happiness of headlines I remarked yeah I
mean there being any of them been
addressed in the popular media and I
think the evidence is incomplete and but
I think the evidence will be forthcoming
and and this it I think will probably go
a long way to reducing or potentially
reducing the incidence of cancer in the
human population so you think the
evidence will come because we have
outdated
about the British breakfast the English
breakfast entirely no 30 years ago it
was debatable whether she is you're
saying 50 years ago it's debatable
whether can't Oh cigarettes cause cancer
and and it's quite clear now I'm it's
completely unequivocal and yeah alcohol
though sometimes do you eat cured
processed meats cook it YouTube if it's
good enough for you professor moderate
well do as I say not as I do
professor Z Sandra because your
particular work focused very much on sun
exposure right to Sun and UVA damage
ultraviolet - there's still some bathe
don't they know that's one of their on
invidious case of the environment being
a carcinogen there is no doubt that sun
exposure ultraviolet causes skin cancer
and yet people do some bit and how you
change people's behavior I don't know
how to do it
when we want to our physics laureates
now take a key character and Arthur
McDonald because you won your prize for
neutrinos telling us that neutrinos
which are this subatomic particle which
is ubiquitous in our universe used to be
thought that it had no mass you've
discovered that it does have some mass
and I understand there are billions of
these things passing through our body
and so on and so forth and in some way
it will help us understand how the
universe works better but anyway that's
a very brief summary of your what you've
won the prize for but let's get our
question from Elizabeth
Elizabet Lillie blood your question
please to the physics laureates do you
think that mankind will benefit in the
future from researchers in fields beyond
applied physics such as astroparticle
physics in more ways than by increasing
our general knowledge of the universe
hmm professor mcdonald the greater
degree to which you can understand the
details of the laws of physics the
better you are to apply such things I'll
give you an example even from such
esoteric and difficult to detect
particles as neutrinos I mean neutrinos
are outside the general experience of
humans maybe once in your lifetime and
the trainer will stop in your body and
change one atom into something else and
you won't even notice it but that's
really the only influence that you have
and and yet there are something like six
billion neutrinos going through your
fingernail per second from the Sun we
use those neutrinos from the Sun to
understand the fusion processes that are
taking place that power the Sun with
great accuracy in fact the puzzle that
we solved that neutrinos do change from
one type to another which implies that
they they have mass I was able to sort
out what could have been a problem with
the calculations of how many neutrinos
are produced and therefore the
understanding of the basic fusion power
of the Sun confined by gravity it's now
been determined that these calculations
are accurate too much better than 10%
those are the same types of calculations
that are being applied to try to harness
fusion power here on earth confined by
magnetic fields and so it's a prime
example of how knowing the pure physics
as accurately as you can enable you then
to apply those laws of physics in trying
to move forward with applied physics hmm
professor cachito I mean it's
interesting that professor arch McDonald
there talks about how I think it's one
of the three types of neutrinos --is is
from the Sun and mentioning this idea of
fusion nuclear fusion is what I want you
to ask you about because a lot of people
are looking at that now as a source of
energy for us I mean that's is there is
this something which your discovery that
neutrinos have mass could perhaps help
us harness nuclear fusion from the Sun
better let me mention the application of
pure physics into the applied science
one another
example not neutrino physics okay well
this year is the 100 years of general
relativity people thought this is really
pure science no application to daily
life
however after why 100 years we cannot
live with that in orage of general
relativity because our GPS is based on
general relativity now we use GPS but if
we have no idea about general relativity
the GPS doesn't work so general
relativity which was thought to be pure
theoretical pure basic science is
irrelevant to our subway to our day life
after 100 years so maybe neutrinos could
also be greater than you know I'm just
gonna bring in Randy Nordstrom I think
you've got a question which is very
related to the answer you've just
already given professor guy character
I'm wondering if you think that focus
academia should be on fundamental
research so to find out how the world
really works or if we should focus more
on application and product development
who'd like to pick pick up on that and
then professor characters already kind
of addressing that we have done that so
I think history is clearly shown as time
after time of the power of knowledge and
knowledge comes from basic science or
basic research and other fields and and
I mean it's hard to develop new things
if you do not understand how the world
works and and that's really the goal of
basic science and I think that's its
intrinsic value I would argue that every
major meta modern medical advance is
directly tied to advanced
in basic science Sweetland Alexeevich I
wanted to ask you because obviously
you're not a scientist but your writing
is very much based on knowledge and
research which you get from the people
you talk to who bear witness to the
upheavals in the events that you have
drawn on for your writings so it really
is picking up professor Maude Rich's
point that you need to anchor what you
do on research in your case talking to
people
yah-hey chose Casa de obras una Simba's
vans a video auto Cassini estoy yeah see
oh sorry dissing embargo
Avada Kedavra Hazuki Levesque oh yeah
hachoo visit no on ho cheat sheet
stow mo mrs. Torrey cultura Tolle
mentalness Tolliver Shaka keator arsenal
Navy she twists at Sheila vehicle
Susheela via KHOU yeah I do mija choose
sobriety otter that obras Remini proud
of Rimini stable no principie SAT really
discussed oppa mochi teacher area
no canas la cadaver Garrity is a combo
diem abortion kakuida de Vos Vlasta
alien voice River chief Takamine Vesuvio
t FG problemo no a kadai apprecia yah
guru evangeline bossy Guevara at
Chernobyl II can asana with resistant
elitist problem with diversity Thank You
professor dating abolishment I I just
wanted to come back a little bit to
compassion and curiosity and you know
fun so I think we all do this I mean
everything I've heard about you know
when you're actually doing the work
you're motivated by curiosity by trying
to resolve puzzles by trying to resolve
paradoxes and so on I also remember Aziz
at a previous meeting saying that one of
the greatest moments in his life is when
he's in the laboratory and he sees
something and he thinks only God and I
for the moment understand those process
and I I mean in my way I can think of
things like that to there's a moment
when I suddenly understand something and
everything fits into place and you know
I just know a whole bunch you know
there's light suddenly where there was
darkness and mist before and that's a
wonderful feeling but so we don't do it
for compassion we do it for that feeling
that aha moment that discovery but you
know it's all within a social context in
which that our funding agencies out
there their society who's deciding which
fields are really important to work on
there's people responding in economics
whenever others like you know in the
Great Depression that was what caused
some of the greatest future Nobel
laureates and other people to move into
economics because if they wanted to help
people so it was the compassion that
drove people into economics its funding
agencies its poverty in the world and
for me it's always been that's for me as
being very direct lovely company makeup
you and I as a scientist I usually think
that what I say no one Assad scientists
paying attention to and I'm really
gratified and very happy that dr. Deaton
has caught me twice today absolutely but
I should say that actually interesting
enough you as Eastern ja or an MD a
medical doctor as you are to tomas
lindahl but you're only lasted one year
as a doctor in you only two years as a
doctor yes so you didn't have the
compassion gene to carry on how they're
really professor Lindo briefly well I
would like to go back to sweat Lana's
comment that we are living the
privileged society we can pursue our
ideas without being regarded with
suspicion by the government I'm old
enough to have had colleagues and done
some work in eastern Germany well a bit
over 35 years ago and it was obvious
that the local scientists they
immediately became my friends to I never
met them before because we had the
common enemy
and the people in great suits were
sitting in the room trying to figure out
if we were doing something subversive in
their mind scientist for the same thing
as terrorists and that was an uneasy
feeling yeah and I think that has
largely disappeared now mm-hmm okay so
we've got some couple of questions now
if I can go to an early Borg first and
then Rubbia Ayub if you could both give
us your point
annalee yes so my question is whether
you would encourage a young person or
student to become a scientist in your
own field okay thank you Rabia a you
what skills do you think were most
important on your way to success okay
thank you
who would like to pick up on an early
Borg would you encourage a young person
or student to become a scientist in your
profession da I have to say let me ask
you because I know that you had a
teacher a chemistry teacher who you
didn't really get on with and who failed
you in fact and yet here you are good at
chemistry laureate how about that it
means that there are some teachers that
are very bad teachers bad
you should be stubborn in science you
shouldn't be easily discouraged
occasionally you meet scientists who
have some idea that's obviously wrong
and they just spend years and years
pursuing that idea but that's
exceptional I think it's much more
common that scientists give up too
easily you have an unusual observation
and nature is telling you something here
you're privileged you have new
information and you shouldn't just put
it in a drawer because you don't
understand it professor Deaton you
actually didn't start off you wanted to
become an economist did you you actually
went into university to study
mathematics and then gave up on it or it
gave up on me I would say one thing
though and some of you not gonna like
this but you know the mathematics I
learned early on has been incredibly
useful to me even though I'm not a
mathematician and there's a very wide
range of Sciences and economics and
other things where mathematics is really
important so you know push yourself as
far as you can in that direction
there's obviously areas where it's more
important than others but it's often
extremely important and it helps you
think very clearly as part of it ozzie
syndrome we all talk about how this or
that teacher made a big difference in
our lives and because they are not paid
well they're not respected in society
our best minds do not go into teaching
and I just hope that through this medium
both young scientists that young people
and their parents encourage their
children the capable intelligent
children to become teachers
and one thing I'd like to say and use
use in example perhaps professor bill
Campbell is that don't be scared of the
contradictions perhaps within you
because I know that you have a huge love
admiration and respect for parasites and
worms and yet ironically you've spent
your life researching how to kill them
right so there's this ambivalence here
but I know in your spare time you like
to paint them you paint worms and when
you met President Barack Obama he gave
you a stuffed animal in the form of a
worm
pride a place in your home and you also
write poems about worms so I'm hoping
that you might be able to give us a
rendition and my poems I sometimes like
to speak on behalf of the worms and give
them a chance to say something and I do
happen to have one in particular a case
for a worm that causes river blindness
in fact I can imagine it been very
frustrated and getting more and more
angry as people accuse it of causing
blindness when blindness in fact is a
chance of shoot of their infection
they're the causative agent is migrating
through the skin all over the body and
some of them are going to end up in the
eye and as humans of course we're very
very unhappy about it but I imagine one
of those worms saying this and you have
to remember that I think they're pretty
frustrated I don't need your goddamn eye
all I need is a piece of skin big enough
to let me drop a few larvae in just
enough to make sure that there will be a
pickup and delivery don't look at me
that way I don't need your goddamn eye
that's the bill Campbell and actually
thank you to all our laureates
spasiba Bolshoi Theatre Alix urvich and
renewed congratulations to all of you
thank you to our students who have given
us questions some encouraging inspiring
and honest words from our Nobel
laureates from me Zana Badawi and all
the team on noble minds from the concert
hall in Stockholm Sweden
goodbye season's greetings and Happy New
Year
you